no
okay a bit of context the individual in
question this woman whose name is anna
um had a brief uh hookup relationship
type of thing and then they ended up
breaking it off and then all of a sudden
there's a lot of bickering and yelling
that happened online over the course of
a year he's been kind of just telling yo
can we just move past this and just stop
being each other's life and she feels
like he's being manipulative so let's
just watch destiny's therapist thought
you're crazy
i mean no therapist would think
someone's just crazy like
because people have reasons because
there's no such thing as like just being
crazy for no reason like people have
reasons for being extremely upset about
things you know would you ever forgive
him after all this or you'll never
forget of course of course i want to
forgive him so badly it's just hard when
like
he doesn't really seem sorry and stuff
i'm not worthy of your forgiveness okay
i just want to move on publicly and
privately
don't you feel bad
you said you felt bad stephen we both
know that you're not like
you're not incapable of remorse or
empathy like i've said this like many
times okay i've defended you about this
why do women love cold men
i don't i don't like being treated
coldly and callously it hurts me very
much it hurts most people
forget it
but i know steven's not like that he's
showing he is very sensitive and kind
what would it take for us to not talk
privately or publicly anymore what would
it take i'm not manipulative at all i
don't understand how i'm manipulating
any why do you say all these like
horrible hurtful things like you don't
it seems like you don't understand that
like so yeah this never ends you see
we've been on this like it ends you're
almost there because you're not showing
any empathy you're not saying like yeah
i i understand how this hurt you and i
feel bad like don't you wanna i
understand i just don't care at all
and i think you
i care i'm sorry the public abuse has
been bad and the public bad statements
have been bad and my community
restaurant has been bad that's why i
deleted all the posts of my subreddit
that's why we try to stop crying with
you for a long time okay we're all
trying to move on we're trying to heal
and move on okay from the pains that i
have caused on my own okay how do we do
that how do we move on
so are you being serious
yes
but like just a few moments ago you were
saying that like you didn't
even you you told me that you understood
that stonewalling and stuff was abusive
like you understood that and now you're
going back on it this is what makes it
so confusing
i don't know what else to do you could
try asking her but it seems like no
matter what i propose or what i say
there is no way to ever move on from
this like what no it's not that stephen
please stop acting like please stop
talking about the i'm like i'm just some
crazy person
like three times in a row what do we do
to move on from this you're not giving
me an answer i just told you i said to
show remorse and empathy and i said i'm
sorry and i understand that you have a
lot of pain thank you what more can you
[ __ ] walk for me you can't probe my
[ __ ] brain with a [ __ ] electrode
and figure out like if i'm being sincere
or not i'm telling you i'm sorry i'm
telling you i'm being empathetic i know
that it sucked i've been harassed online
too i've had people [ __ ] with me it's
bad okay it sucks i'm sorry but now we
have to move on
okay
thanks
i appreciate that stephen yes you're
welcome okay now we're moving on we're
not publicly or privately communicating
anymore yes
if if that's what you want yeah no
no
you just [ __ ] made me watch nerd
drama
nerd days of our lives here
for this [ __ ]
making a thing of it out of a thing
that's not a thing if that's what you
want [ __ ] you don't
oh
wow
that was annoying
shut the [ __ ] up
god damn it
it's not real problems
you with the dude you're not with the
dude you thought he was the man of your
life he's not move on stop talking to
the dude no empathy shut the [ __ ] up
move the [ __ ] on
i thought he was about to be the man
he's not next you're wasting time here
[ __ ]
don't drive like a [ __ ] comic-con to
go to
[ __ ] prep your next costume for
kutakon or whatever it's called it's
called twitchcon i don't give a [ __ ]
tell them jesus christ
that's not real problems
can i appreciate it you guys ain't got
[ __ ]
you ain't got [ __ ] to do in your life
you guys are bored
muff
you're bored that's not a thing
but do you see what i'm saying earlier
about how like they don't want the
dynamic to end no they don't they want
conflict because there's an emotional
connection because that's the only thing
that's going to get them there that
that's going to keep the connection okay
we don't have the love we don't have the
faith that the hate the only thing we
have is conflict so let's keep that
alive no boo boo your cat is dead or
your dog is dead what if it's dead okay
it's dead it's [ __ ] dead
stop all right let's keep going and
after that we want a resolution let's
move on platform this let's knock him in
okay if you have what you want if that's
what you want
wow but i mean you know it's always been
different and okay
that [ __ ] yeah that [ __ ] yes
yeah nerd nerd ass drama yes this person
got blocked on multiple platforms found
a different platform to still contact
started publicly posting about it it's
like
yeah
yeah okay some people i i i promise you
this um um
oh my mama oh my mama of your mama some
[ __ ] out here
they need to be connected and so they
don't give a [ __ ] about how they do it
they will hold the [ __ ] hostage
emotionally by just constantly seeking
out problems why because let me tell you
guys let me put you guys on some game
imagine there's a spectrum
okay
and if on one end there's love
on the opposite end it's not hate nope
it's crazy
it's a difference
it's indifferent
but
close but not
how many times have you said you hated a
[ __ ] and y'all was [ __ ] afterwards
in a relationship well how many times
you about to break up with somebody and
then y'all turn it around and you're
back together it can flip but in
different ways once you're indifferent
now you win a different ballgame on your
mama so you have to understand even
though she's saying all these negative
things about the mane
even though she says he's stonewalling
he's terrible he's a piece of [ __ ] he
apologizes he says i [ __ ] up let's
stop talking
yep she wants to suck that she wants to
turn that hate into love because they're
right beside each other they're
neighbors she still wants their sign
means twins you can't separate the
[ __ ] that's why they say man i
love this [ __ ] but i hate her yup how
many times you heard that mm-hmm
that's what happens she wants to assess
that dnd whatever the [ __ ] you nerds say
be easy bro don't be throwing me in
there
yeah this is twitch so this is extra
nerd yeah i know but all you guys here
who watching right now who watch this
twitch stuff big time nurse but but that
but that's but that's the thing that's
exactly what it is i wouldn't go to
youtube but i'm going to talk with
someone that that that's really the
thing with that conversation like that
you could be blocked and i was at the
gym four days ago and every now and then
so this is this is a cycle of how our
friendship works everything will be okay
and then she'll message me and she's
like well you were so horrible for so
many years ago and then when she starts
doing that then i'm like okay listen if
i was so horrible why are you still
talking to me why the [ __ ] you still
talk to me stop talking to me that's
what i say because i don't know why i
don't know why you said stop you
deliberately said that yes
that's it it's her fault can i please
please please please just let me talk
please stop
you can make things
why do you say these things different
bugs publicly steven privately why
didn't you say
you wanted to talk to me steven why do
you act like you did it
stop acting like that
why did you
why would you call me princess
a month ago
you just not care
i thought you understood me
[Laughter]
why would he call me princess
he didn't want to talk to me so you've
been lying the whole time
this whole time you just feel like
you're forced to be friends with me
why wouldn't you say that
why did you say all those sweet things
listen mind you i'm gonna speak to the
ladies for two seconds ladies ladies
ladies i know you're not
i know you're not
but this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] right here right here this
[ __ ] is the reason why they called you
crazy yes cause this is crazy yes if
he's not a little bit jealous he don't
care
i swear to god i'm not crazy when you
say that because you know you've done
that you done did some crazy [ __ ] you
shut that [ __ ] off yeah i think we could
pretty much get it done with but i want
to play something for you that i thought
was really interesting okay so this is
somebody else who had a problem with her
a woman okay you end up feeling like
you're being held hostage
so do you still get messages like
constantly i know you say you're getting
some now but like you get like the same
like 20 messages in a row with no
response thing that steve got or what
if she's really upset yeah
one thing that she would do
is she said that um
i just have a wrong version like i view
reality wrong because
i thought that when you tell somebody to
stop messaging you that they're supposed
to stop and she said that like
the way that it actually is is that if
you say if you tell somebody to stop it
means that you aren't gonna read the
messages anymore but you can keep
sending them
so stuff like that made me really feel
like i was insane because it's like was
i really being like
horrible by like
expecting people to stop when they say
stop if they're messaging me
i'ma tell you this this sounds
crazy
it sounds great it's not
it's much more common than you think yep
most of you
are like that
when someone tells you okay stop stop
that you can't
you can't compel to because there's a
break you still want to have that
relationship no matter how toxic it is
this is very very common if you want to
talk about
no means no i could assure you
emotionally with a lot of ladies it does
not it does not okay
the amount of times that i did not want
to have a conversation i didn't want to
talk about something or i didn't want to
talk to somebody and they kept going
yeah
and ladies you guys might know this you
guys ever had a guy who said you're not
interested he keeps messaging you and he
sends you 100 messages yeah yeah
a lot of ladies do that [ __ ] too
absolutely a lot of ladies with that
[ __ ] emotionally you guys do exactly
that and i told you i got a lot of
female friends
yeah but why do you keep messaging
because i need to let them know how i
feel for what you already know you
already know you know okay go ahead and
it's the same [ __ ] that we're saying
before
no i just i just got it i got something
to do
now walk it off
is it groundhog day i have to ask
you said we need to talk while we talk
about what we talk about yesterday and
then when you abdicate you're like you
know what you know what okay go ahead
it's the same
and this is what i'm saying but you said
that already
and this is what i'm saying i'm so
grateful for the people in my life we
talk about some [ __ ] we hash it out we
move the [ __ ]
because i'm gonna start looking at you
funny if you always bringing up the same
problems and we already
and handled that [ __ ]
then it sounds to me like you're trying
to hold me hostage with my fuck-up
i apologize if i repeat the behavior
talk to me about it okay yo [ __ ] you
did that [ __ ] again okay now we can talk
again about it because it's not the same
thing what is it it's a pattern now we
gotta talk about that if it's the same
old [ __ ] though no you need to shut the
[ __ ] up about it and move on and that's
what i'm saying you emotionally holding
someone hostage bro i don't [ __ ] with
that i do not
i do not
and some of you weirdos out there who
are sending 30 messages without replies
if someone says don't reach out to them
don't reach out to them
respect their
privacy rough
anyways i don't know
that's one of those things that i've
been seeing so many times and i'm just
like bro i don't this is not necessary
but it's more common than i do you think
it's not crazy the reason why
we say it's crazy because it's [ __ ] up
but it's not crazy yes it's it's it's
there it's not out of the norm it's
really out there it's not and you know
what the thing is is like if you're a
half decent person you just want to find
a way to resolve this as peacefully as
possible so everyone go their separate
ways but when someone doesn't want to
and they're messaging other people and
they're posting stuff and they're
sending you well do you know how [ __ ]
weird it is when you block someone on
one platform then they message you on
another one then you block them there
and they message you on another one then
you block them there and by the final
message they're saying the most foul
things you can imagine because they're
just angry and they want an emotional
response the amount of times that i've
seen that [ __ ] i'm just like yo
i didn't told you stop contacting
they're gonna go in personal shape you
were doing some [ __ ] [ __ ] i said cool
let's stop talking you out here
messaging me on every platform i don't
reciprocate
if you gave me
[ __ ] crazy man like that kind of
controlling hostage
i'm america you don't negotiate with uh
thank you we don't we don't we don't
okay
you sure so oh okay you're gonna hold
that [ __ ] over my head you know what
kill the hostage i'm going home [ __ ]
i'm not a good hostage taker but i try
not to get to a lot of hostage
situations so that's all i'mma say about
this all you [ __ ] nut jobs out there
who'll be doing this [ __ ] who don't know
how to let stuff go let it breathe
breathe but you're not you're not trying
to get into us breathe you're not
one and two and you're not trying to get
it no no no no no no no
blue
oh
you say you love
[Music]
happy
oh no [ __ ] i gotta play that
could just appreciate that's one that's
an all-time classic yeah yeah for me i'm
saying not in general but blue can
trailer
shot shot two hits so the first intro
[Music]
yes that's a good one
when i actually put her name in that's
the first one
just a little i had a little pause for
y'all you know we was talking about some
crazy [ __ ] this whole time so i figured
give you all a little pause and blue
crazy
good times baby
acting crazy
say you love me say you love me but
you're never there for me
[Applause]
this [ __ ] kills it i gotta give it to
you
yo this [ __ ] is a jukebox yo listen who
wants to talk about the music no no no
no
that song in particular
breathe
so all this to say
guys one of the best skills in life that
you're ever going to learn is to learn
to walk away from conflicts how to
resolve conflicts and sometimes you
gotta let [ __ ]
go
let it slide leave breathe
shut the [ __ ] up you gotta let it
breathe air it out see sometimes you
gotta
sometimes you gotta you know let it
breathe let it breathe let it breathe
i let it rain now rock it out
okay after you let it rain
you walk it out
so anyways that's all and once you get
one get out
let's get it let's get it skinny let's
get in this
let it rain now rinse it out no walk it
out is it walking out yeah let it rain
don't rinse it i feel like it's rinsing
out am i crazy walk it out okay
i said rinse it out but clear it out it
was pretty much the same [ __ ] yeah but
it's not different yeah but it's not
walking out though because i was like i
knew it wasn't walking out no it's right
no you're getting you're okay okay okay
not crazy all right because i'm gonna
use the jukebox i think it's not gonna
be wrong yeah yeah okay
anyways leave your comments below